and you think no I wouldn't do that it's
like that's not what the evidence
suggests uh this is Jordan Peterson on
how Ordinary Decent Germans became
genocidal
Nazis many many many many of the people
not all many of the people who were
involved in the Nazi atrocities were
perfectly Ordinary People they were just
like you and you think no I wouldn't do
that it's like that's not what the
evidence suggests
the evidence suggests that the vast
majority of people in Nazi Germany went
along with it now not all of them were
dragged into the abyss itself but plenty
were and if you think you wouldn't have
been one of them that just means it's
highly likely that you would have
because you have no idea what you're
capable of there's a great book about
that it's terrifying book called
Ordinary men and it's about the
initiation of a police Battalion from
Germany who went to Poland after the
Germans March mared into Poland now
these were ordinary men they were
policemen middle-aged who had grown up
before the Nazi propaganda Mill got
going okay so they weren't indoctrinated
Nazis from like the time they were four
they're just ordinary middle class guys
plus their Commander told them in Poland
when they were starting to do military
work even though they were civilian
policemen that they could go home that
they didn't have to do this job and that
there would be no repercussions and in
fact out of the Battalion a number of
men right at the beginning said I'm not
doing this and they went home Mo the
vast majority went along now the guys
that left thought I don't care I'm not
doing this but most people didn't and
part of the reason they didn't do it is
because they were loyal to their to
their peers by the end of this which
took months these guys were taking n
naked pregnant women out into the middle
of fields and shooting them in the back
of the
head get the point I think you get the
point right if all of the people who
right now are trying to stand up for
their Nations let the Netherlands be for
the Dutch let Ireland be for the Irish
let America be for Americans and by the
way that's a little more complex because
we are a Melting Pot but we do have a
culture worth defending and we have laws
worth defending and a founding worth
defending and all those things if we
will not allow those things to happen
What will come on the other side are
much worse people who will do
unspeakable things then good people that
we all know will also do unspeakable
things for the very reasons that Jordan
just laid out right I I've mentioned it
a couple times over the years that when
Jordan and I used to tour he would ask
often we did you know hundred some odd
shows and I'd say he did it probably 30
40 times how many of you here in front
of five six thousand people how many of
you here would have been a Nazi and of
course nobody applauds nobody raises
their hand and as he just laid out in
that clip that means you probably would
have been because these people were not
all in completely indoctrinated
four-year-olds that s you know that that
grew up with all the wrong ideas and
then said okay let's kill all these
people right but then one day they're
shooting pregnant women out in the field
it's because over time if you are pushed
far enough and then the wrong ideas come
in and then Society starts turning and
no one else is good around and then you
don't want to be on the wrong side of
being shot too humans can do horrible
things to each other so I think the West
has has a kind of interesting moment
right now we can choose which way we
want to go I think you know which way I
want to go which way do you want to
go